sie haben für Deutschland ihr Leben
riskiert und jetzt haben sie ein Befehl
verweigert den impfbefehl warum wollten
Sie sich nicht impfen lassen und was hat
das jetzt für Konsequenzen für sie ihre
Zeit ja ich bin nun seit knapp 12 Jahren
Soldat bei der Bundeswehr war die
letzten sechs Jahre davon in einer
spezialisierten Einheit mit zwei
Auslandseinsätzen in Afghanistan und ich
bin deutschlandweit die habe die
zweithöchste militärische taktische
Sanitäter Sanitäter Ausbildung und
musste mich zwangsläufig auch mit folgen
und Nebenwirkungen von Impfungen
beschäftigen sonst hätte ich keine Rede
und Antwort meinen Jungs gegenüber
stehen können und für mich kam dann
irgendwann der Punkt dass der Druck und
auch der Zwang einfach viel zu groß
waren und auch meine Bedenken viel zu
groß um guten Gewissens diese Impfungen
entgegenzunehmen und deswegen sitze ich
auch heute hier für alle Pflegekräfte
für alle Soldaten für alle Mediziner die
diese Impfpflicht in den Institutionen
in den Einrichtung
mitmachen mussten und ebenfalls auch
solche Zwangsmaßnahmen und Strafen über
sich ergehen lassen mussten und ja das
beschäftigt mich nach wie vor und
gedroht aktuell sogar meine Existenz mit
Zahlungen die mir entgehen von knapp 150
bis 200.000 Euro und eine unehrenhafte
Entlassung die nach all dieser Zeit
jetzt droht und die mir ja angedroht
wird auch nach wie vor um mich in diese
Impfung zu bringen
wie gehen sie derzeit damit um das ist
ein wahnsinniger Druck der auf ihn
lastet das ist ein finanzieller Druck
ich stelle mir vor das ist auch ein
psychischer Druck der da auf ihn leistet
psychischer Druck allein schon durch die
Einsätze der nicht ganz so einfach zu
verkraften war in den ich auch viele
Tiefschläge hatte auch die ich mich dann
zum Glück selber rausziehen konnte aber
jetzt so langsam haben wir natürlich
auch einen Punkt erreicht an dem man zu
mir sagt man möchte mich unehrenhaft
entlassen und halt mir alle Gelder
streichen die mehr eigentlich mein Zivil
Leben erleichtern sollte oder den
Einstieg wieder ins Zivil Leben
erleichtern sollten oder überhaupt erst
mal möglich machen sollten und dass mir
jetzt alles wegnehmen zu wollen ist
ja wir hatten Formen im Vorgespräch als
hätte man 12 Jahre nichts getan und
möchte jetzt einfach den Mann aus so ein
Stück weit kalt stellen und ruhig
stellen wie fühlt sich das für sie an
sie haben das angesprochen die schwere
Zeit ich nehme an sie sprechen ihren
Einsatz in Afghanistan an der mit
Sicherheit sehr schwierig war für sie
wie fühlt es sich für Sie an aufgrund
ihrer persönlichen Entscheidung
mittlerweile ist beispielsweise die
einrichtungsbezogene Pflicht ja auch
gefallen nur in der Bundeswehr nicht
dass das was sie dort geleistet haben
sind ihr Leben riskiert für Deutschland
das in dieses Geld das ihnen zusteht für
diesen Einsatz jetzt weggenommen werden
soll aufgrund ihrer persönlichen
Entscheidung
nun ja
das eine ist mein mein persönliches Leid
was ich dadurch erfahre aber es ist
nicht so dass ich ja die Augen
verschließe vor den Sachen die sonst
noch in der Bundeswehr passieren wir
sind in meiner Einheit und ich will da
gar nicht zu sehr ins Detail gehen aber
wir sind überdurchschnittlich fitte und
gesunde junge Männer gewesen und jetzt
habe ich in den letzten Monaten seitdem
diese Impfkampagne auch durchgezogen
wurde halt leider gesehen bei uns dass
alle ausnahmslos zwei bis dreimal Corona
hatten teilweise schwere Verläufe und
teilweise auch solche Verläufe dass man
sagt der Mann der konnte nicht mehr
gehen das war schon anstrengend für ihn
und jetzt haben wir die Problematik das
ist bei uns flächendeckend so war jeder
einzelne außer ein hat es nicht erwischt
und der sitzt vor ihm
sie sind auch da für die anderen
für die die genauso geimpften haben
Corona bekommen und sie
und jetzt kann man natürlich denken ich
bin vielleicht der Patient Null wie in
den ganzen Zombie Apokalypse Filmen dass
ich irgendwas besonderes habe ich achte
sehr auf meine Gesundheit und auf meine
Fitness und das machen die anderen Jungs
von uns aber auch
und nur diese seit diesem Vorfall ist da
jetzt eine Veränderung die da
stattgefunden hatten das macht mich sehr
nachdenklich ich meine ich habe vorher
schon Statistiken und auch Studien
gelesen und mich damit der beschäftigt
aber das jetzt noch mal so zu sehen ist
echt erdrückend
angesprochen die einrichtungsbezogene
Impfpflicht die läuft Ende des Jahres
aus was gibt es überhaupt doch für einen
Argument diese in der Bundeswehr
aufrecht zu halten
kann aus meiner Sicht überhaupt kein
Argument geben das irgendwo noch
aufrecht zu erhalten man hätte auch
jetzt schon längst die abschaffen sollen
und nicht einfach nur auslaufen lassen
auf dem kleinen verkalten Verfahrensweg
ich bin deshalb eher ich kann sie den
Fall vorher nicht ich bin deshalb
erschüttert zum einen weil wir doch alle
denken Glauben hoffen und eigentlich
auch wissen dass es sich um eine
parlamentarmee handelt in der der Bürger
in Uniform gefahren ist der Bürger in
Uniform und ein so schwieriger
schwieriger entscheide dass ich mich
irgendwie dass ich nicht körperlich
Integrität wird verletzt die sollte
glaube ich auch an diesem Bürger ein
Uniform überlassen werden zumal wir
wissen dass es dass sie eben von dem
Selbstschutz dient also er schützt jetzt
zunächst einmal nicht andere und zum
zweiten finde ich es eben sehr sehr
schüttern erschüttern dass man aufgrund
wenn man dieses Recht seine eines
mündigen Bürgers sich zu eigen macht
wenn man dann bedroht wird mit einer wie
Sie sagten unehrenhaften Entlassung also
ich hätte auf jeden Fall wie gesagt noch
nicht gehört ich hätte mir das nicht
vorstellen können warum es kann ja
eigentlich eine Erklärung geben man will
ein extern bis datieren man will sagen
wir haben hier diese Verordnung ob die
ausläuft aber nicht zu wissen ist jetzt
haben wir sie noch und wenn sie bis zum
30.12 Geld und du machst es nicht
entlassen wir dich zur Not am 31.12 also
man will eine examples tatuieren und das
finde ich sehr sehr schade weil man hat
auch sehr viele Bereiche wo man den
Eindruck hat da wird es mit der Ordnung
vielleicht nicht so genau genommen und
hier wo man sich jetzt auf einen klaren
Verfahrensweg gerufen kann will man ein
exempostatuiert und riskiert vielleicht
einen Menschen zu brechen wenn es okay
käme also ich kann nur hoffen dass es
nicht dazu kommt mir fällt dieses
Verständnis
Soldaten allein das geht überhaupt nicht
was ich hier höre also
sie sind jetzt gar nicht mehr in der
Bundeswehr sondern sie haben eine Zeit
wo sie sich jetzt auf ihren Beruf
außerhalb der bundesvorbereitet das
heißt sie sind auch immer im aktivieren
das möchte ich gerade noch mal dazu
sagen ja ich habe den aktiven Dienst vor
drei Monaten verlassen ich bin nicht mal
mehr in der Kaserne und trotzdem hat man
vor drei Wochen den Befehl wiederholt
mit dem expliziten Zusatz eben diese
existenziellen Bedrohung dass man mich
ungernhaft entlassen möchte und Halt die
ganzen Gelder streichen möchte und
demzufolge natürlich für mich auch das
Studium gar nicht finanzierbar wäre
hätte ich nicht diese Gelder und damit
natürlich auch alles andere nicht mehr
bezahlbar wäre Wohnung etc also das
kommt noch dazu aber ich bin weder in
der Kaserne noch sonst irgendwie was
ihnen bringe ich jetzt das Versprechen
ab dass sie sich einsetzen
an die Bundesregierung erstens wir den
Fall schildern und ähm wo ist die
Bundesregierung davon hält dass jemand
der Kunde mit der Bundeswehr ist
sozusagen
nichts mehr zu tun haben ist der erste
Punkt der zweite Punkt ist der ich
wusste jetzt gar nicht dass es war nicht
mein Thema im Gesundheitsausschuss bin
ich nicht ich wusste gar nicht dass die
Bundeswehr auch eine Impfpflicht hatte
sehen Sie und da haben wir jetzt ihr
Versprechen das geht natürlich also
schwierig an dieser Stelle bedanke ich
mich ganz herzlich bedanke mich vor
allem bei Ihnen Herr Müller dass sie das
hier geschildert haben ihnen wenn
versprechende abgerungen und da werden
wir weiter auch darauf schauen